bonjour à toutes et à tous
je remercie tout d'abord l'organisation
d'avoir permis de démarrer puisque en
fait je
rires la librairie on
je pourrais pas rester très longtemps
avec nous je suis donc françois xavier
schmitt en quelques secondes
gk pas du milieu de la librairie puisque
j'étais pendant dix ans des rage dans
deux sociétés avec un losange dont ceux
qui reconnaissent
ensuite j'ai créé ma propre librairie à
toulouse en france s'appelle l'autre
rive il ya de cela sept ans donc c'est
des changements de vie qui sont assez
importants en termes personnels et
financiers aussi puisque le métier de
libraire un métier passion mais c'est
pas un métier qui rapporte beaucoup donc
quand on lance sa propre librairie faut
vous dire qu'on va faire quelques
sacrifices
et puis donc il ya un peu plus d'un an
j'ai rejoint
les services culturels de l'ambassade de
france où on a monté la librairie
albertine peut-être effectivement
certains connaissent qui a ouvert en
septembre dernier est donc six mois
quasiment jour pour jour
donc je voulais avec vous rapidement
essayé de faire un peu un panorama de la
librairie aujourd'hui la librairie en
général la librairie française et puis
la librairie sur new york
les librairies les libraires et des
métiers qui existent depuis plusieurs
siècles
c'est un métier qu'aujourd'hui un petit
peu en difficulté pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord parce que le livre qui
aujourd'hui un peu la seule source
d'information pendant très longtemps
maintenant en concurrence avec tout un
tas d'autres médias d'autres supports et
ça c'est tant mieux
et puis par l'arrivée également dans
même le texte de supports différents
comme le numérique qui sont maintenant
devenu un réflexe pour un certain nombre
d'entre nous
moi j'ai du mal à me faire mais parce
que j'ai déjà trop vieux je sais qu'une
nouvelle génération switch au delà de
l'un à l'autre
une ivresse est important dans une ville
dans un pays parce que c'est un lieu de
savoir c'est un lieu d'imagination les
livres c'est un espace de liberté pour
le lecteur pour l'auteur pour la
personne qui la diffuse
et c'est clair que une société qui
commencent à refuser la libre
circulation des livres c'est arrivé dans
l'histoire il a pas si longtemps mais
c'est aussi encore en train d'arriver en
ce moment j'ai regardé les actualités un
des premiers trucs le fond les
dictateurs ou les régimes un petit peu
dur c'est de supprimer les livres c'est
qu'il doit y avoir une raison
ce que je vous disais au début le livre
c'est un espace de libertés et quand on
a envie de de tordre le cou à la liberté
dans s'attaque au lit alors comment
fonctionne une librairie aujourd'hui
j'ai d'abord partir de l'exemple
français est un bon exemple parce que je
pense que pour une fois être le meilleur
au monde
il ya une trentaine d'années il y a
un ministre de la culture s'appelait
jacques lang qu'a fait passer une loi
avec l'aide des éditeurs français il a
fait baptiser mois qui s'appelle le prix
unique du livre veut dire qu'en france
dans quelques commerces que ce soit vous
alliez dans une grande surface du nord
libre et dans une petite librairie le
prix du livre elle même alors ça l'air
de rien mais c'est très très important
pourquoi parce que ça veut dire que les
grandes sociétés les grandes compagnies
qui dans d'autres pays peuvent casser
les prix en france on peut pas le faire
ça permet une diversité mais de tous les
acteurs de la chaîne du livre aussi bien
des auteurs mais des éditeurs et des
libraires
du coup on a beaucoup plus de choix et
donc les librairies indépendantes arrive
à peu près à survivre en france qui
n'est pas le cas dans quasiment la
plupart des pays au monde y compris les
unit est inclus je vais revenir je pas
rentrer trop dans la technique mais
quand vous avez un livre vous avez un
prix donc on va dire qu'il est un grand
format et à 20 euros sur ces 20 euros il
va falloir que évidemment l'auteur
récupère un petit peu c'est évident faut
pas croire qu'ils touchent beaucoup un
auteur il touche à peu près 10% les plus
grands auteurs vont peut-être qu'à 14 15
% du prix de vente mais ça peut
descendre jusqu'à 7,8 même pour les
auteurs qui démarre faut que l'éditeur
qui a pris des risques en publiant un
livre qui se touchent et un petit peu
donc l'éditeur également on va récupérer
quelque chose va y avoir le distributeur
c'est celui qui fait la diffusion du
livre il ya vers le transporteur et
enfin va y avoir le libre et donc du
coup les parts de gâteaux sont assez
sont assez faibles mais en tout cas en
ayant un prix unique du livre
cette économie est très fragile arrive à
tenir ce qui fait qu'en france vous avez
le plus grand réseau de librairies
indépendantes au monde
vous allez à paris quand vous comparez
paris à new york le ratio est peut-être
deux indices quasiment vous avez au
moins au moins une cinquantaine de bonis
morin à paris à new york juste après
c'est beaucoup plus difficile
donc voilà le système le système
français il a des défauts mais en tout
cas il a une qualité c'est qu'il
respecte l'ensemble des acteurs de la
chaîne du livre et y fait que c'est une
économie qui bon an mal an arrive à peu
près à ce
à se maintenir là il ya quelques jours
on a appris la fermeture de la une
peut-être certains connaissent à paris
qu une très très grande librairie assez
mythique
pourquoi tout simplement parce que le
loyer était devenu trop cher et c'est ce
qui se passe dans beaucoup de centres
villes de grandes villes dans le monde
et à new york en particulier
voilà donc je vais pas m'attarder dessus
mais donc moyenne six ans j'ai créé ma
librairie en partant d'une feuille
blanche puisque je n'ai d'un autre un
autre métier et pas besoin d'avoir
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent de côté avant
de démarrer une librairie parce que en
gros à part le stock de livres
il n'y a pas trop d'investissement en
revanche il faut dire que pendant quatre
ou cinq ans on va rien gagner et même
après ça va être ça va être dur pour les
raisons que vous expliquer tout à
l'heure c'est que les acteurs sont
nombreux dans la chaîne du livre et et
c'est vraiment un métier de passion donc
moi j'étais ouvert 7 jours sur 7 de
travailler cinq ans quasiment tous les
jours de l'année
j'étais vers dimanche matin c'était pas
très court en france mais je m'éclatais
complètement et j'étais ravi arrive de
là dessus le projet de la librairie
albertine alors très rapidement
l'environnement de new york
depuis quelques années de nombreuses
librairies indépendantes ont fermé pour
les raisons que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure c'est à dire notamment les prix
des loyers dans les centres villes des
villes américaines
ça c'est la première raison l'arrivée
également du numérique de manière
beaucoup plus soudaine et violente en
france puisque aujourd'hui numérique aux
états unis représentent plus de 25 % les
gens qui nous lisent sur tablettes du
marché en france ont encore qu'à un
ennemi en france mais toujours un peu en
retard et décalé par rapport aux états
unis il semblerait que c'est plus
profond que ça cirque la courbe a du mal
à démarrer
aux etats unis c'est un fait avéré donc
c'est vrai qu'au départ ça a eu quelques
conséquences sur les libraires
indépendants puis comme n'y a pas de
support j'allais dire de l'état et des
collectivités pour supporter libre et
indépendante
ils ont commencé à fermer les unes après
les autres alors ce soit aussi bien des
grandes chaînes
même le barnes and noble se réduisent la
voilure que des grandes librairies qui
étaient présentes depuis longtemps
à new york il ya six mois la librairie
jolly vient de fermer et six ou sept ans
avant et on va donc rejoindre albertine
la librairie du rockefeller center qui
était la seule librairie qui proposait
des livres en français à new york a
également fermé ses portes pour
exactement les mêmes raisons le prix du
loyer était dans les temps devenu
totalement délirant donc face à ça les
services culturels de l'ambassade de
france sont dit c'est quand même dommage
qu'avec plus de cent mille français sur
new yor plus un certain nombre de gens
qui pratiquent la langue ligne et plus
d'offres de livres en français alors y
en avait bien quelques uns chez rizzoli
justement et puis à part ça c'était très
difficile de les avoir en plus été très
cher donc la plupart des jambes a pesé
comme tout le monde soit ils en venaient
avec dans leurs valises tout un tas de
livres soit il commandait sur des sites
s'étaient pas toujours donné non plus en
termes de shipping donc il ya trois
antonin baudry qui était le conseiller
culturel de l'ambassade de france a une
idée à mon avis génial de dire ben on a
un beau bâtiment on est assez bien situé
pourquoi est ce qu on n'essaiera pas de
créer une libre et un intérieur de ces
deux bâtiments
donc ça a pris trois ans à monter comme
projet pour plein de raisons que je vais
vous expliquer
la première était qu'il fallait avoir
les autorisations
en termes de bâtiments de la ville de
new york c'est à dire qu'avec le
bâtiment étant ce qu il était face à la
5e avenue et d'un père de d'autorisation
avoir pour avoir la possibilité de faire
commerce de livres à cet endroit là les
normes de sécurité etc
ensuite il a fallu monter un budget
pourquoi parce que dans ce projet n'y a
pas un dollar qui provient de l'état
français ce ne sont que des fonds privés
qui ont permis la création de cette
libraire seul avantage qu'ont acquis et
pas des moindres c'est qu'on est hébergé
par les services culturels
mais il a fallu faire une levée de fonds
chose qui est totalement invraisemblable
quand on est en france chose qui est
totalement naturel quand on vit aux
états unis ça fait partie des
différences culturelles sur entre les
deux pays donc antonin baudry a pris son
petit bâton de pèlerin qui il a été voir
un certain nombre d'investisseurs qui
ont répondu assez favorablement à ses
attentes et on a réussi à réunir une
petite somme intéressante pour pouvoir
démarrer le projet ensuite il a fallu
choisir qu'est ce qu'on voulait faire
comme comme librairie alors il y avait
plusieurs consultations certaines idées
reprenaient quelque chose de très
moderne avec très peu de livres avec des
écrans partout moi je suis arrivé à ce
moment là ça me paraissait un petit peu
bizarre c'était pas tellement mon
univers et puis finalement on a opté
pour quelque chose pour ceux qui sont
déjà venus les pu constater en fait de
respecter énormément l'endroit donc une
motion du début du xxème en recréant une
ambiance de bibliothèque un peu 19e
18ème avec des canapés des endroits on
peut on peut profiter
on peut s'asseoir on peut rester
longtemps à travailler ou à simplement
de bouquiner et donc on a demandé à
jacques garcia qui est un grand
décorateur français de s'occuper du
design de la librairie donc les travaux
ont duré six mois
ça a été assez
assez assez délicat ça peut paraître
long six mois mais en fait qu'un jour
avant c'était une catastrophe aérienne
czech on a réussi en 15 jours a terminé
et puis en parallèle de ça moi mon
travail c'était d'arriver donc à créer
des liens commerciaux et des biens
logistique avec la france de manière à
constituer le stock
il ya quatorze mille livres dans cette
librairie fallait donc choisir un par un
donc ça peut paraître fastidieux
moi je trouve ça passionnant parce qu'en
fait c'est ce qui donne l'identité de la
librairie la la ligne directrice est
libre et donc on va fouiller chez les
éditeurs les livres qu'on veut avoir
dans la librairie puis après on signe
des contrats avec ses éditeurs et ses
distributeurs et ensuite il faut trouver
un moyen d'acheminer les livres à temps
toutes les semaines ce qui veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui on est livré une fois par
semaine et que quand on commande un
livre on l'a entre deux et trois
semaines si tout va bien qu est ce qu un
délai relativement acceptable pour
quelqu'un qui souhaite aller voilà donc
on a on a fait tout ça on a voulu aussi
une librairie qui soit totalement
ouverte sur la culture américaine c'est
à dire que vous avez des livres en
français vous avez aussi des livres
d'auteurs français traduit dans la
langue anglaise puisque notre rôle en
tant que mission culturelle et librairie
a fortiori c'est que nous soyons le
relais des livres en français des
auteurs français mais également dans
leur dimension internationale c'est à
dire de mettre en avant la place des
auteurs certes classique mais aussi
contemporain dans dans un lieu de
culture tels que cette librairie donc ça
veut dire qu'un auteur qui a été traduit
à six mois en anglais un bon auteur
julien n'importe quoi emmanuel carrère
gée par maylis de kerangal le livre on
l'a tout de suite et on le met bien en
avant pour que les américains découvrent
cas aussi des écrivains contemporains
français qui fonctionne faut savoir
qu'en france dans une librairie vous
avez à peu près 50% de vivre en français
50% de livres traduits aux états unis la
proportion ses 98 %
le livre l'auteur américain et 2% de
livres étrangers traduit le parmi ses 2
% presque un tiers sont des auteurs
français c'est déjà pas si mal
mais vous voyez bien le déséquilibre qui
a donc c'est notre rôle aussi de les
mettre en avant
et puis dernière chose on a voulu un
espace aussi de rencontres entre les
deux les deux publics donc on organise à
peu près deux à trois fois par semaine
des event la gagne à tout à l'heure pour
les enfants à 11 heures donc je vais
rejoindre ses lectures de contes pour
enfants la plupart sont pour adultes
donc on essaie de faire des rencontres
d'écrivains d'artistes de penseurs de
poètes voilà de manière à ce que et en
général on essaie de lier à la fois un
français avec un américain pour le faire
discuter justement ensemble sur les
différences ou les
les similarités entre les entre les deux
cultures voilà donc c'est un espace et
de lecture mais aussi de réflexion de
pensée de débat et dans le monde actuel
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
très important de pouvoir
de temps en temps se poser pour pour
écouter ce que je pense qu'on va dire
les gens voilà je vous remercie de votre
attention
après bientôt de matinée